[Music]
there was a major development over the
weekend in the jeffrey epstein mystery
because fundamentally it
is on the most basic level still a
mystery
the development involves the ceo of
apollo global management that's one of
the top investment firms in the world
fox's matt finn has been following the
story and joins us tonight with an
update hey matt
tucker apollo's former ceo leon black is
stepping down after an investigation
into his ties with jeffrey epstein
revealed black
paid epstein 158 million dollars for
fees related to tax and estate planning
even black's yacht
but new details from a pro by an outside
law firm insist there's no evidence that
black was involved in epstein's crimes
black even denied wrongdoing and
condemned epstein's conduct
but the deckard law firm says it
reviewed more than 60
000 documents more than 20 witnesses
were interviewed and portions of that
investigation
reads quote epstein would at times
allude to their personal relationship
when attempting to negotiate aspects of
their business
relationship and epson made repeated
efforts to ingratiate himself with other
senior executives at apollo and
beginning in 2016.
black and epstein's professional and
personal relationship deteriorated
over a payment dispute that had long
been brewing with black refusing to pay
epstein tens of millions of dollars that
epstein believed he
had earned the report says leon black
believed epstein
saved him up to 2 billion in taxes
black asked for the outside review of
their relationship
tucker matt finn thanks so much for that